[Music]
[Music]
lazy down bad dragon back to your lair
adult man hey buddy don't wipe off my
kisses what you're wearing your dad's
sweatshirt you know that's the manticore
oh great and powerful Manticore I
understand there's traffic you need to
plan for that maybe your mother should
get her own car your fearlessness sir
my brother and I seek a map to a Phoenix
Jim oh well you've come to the right
time I have the parchment you desire
right here oh the children's menu isn't
that fun they're all based on my old
maps uh-oh uh-oh
the great magic or since you on your
adventure with a hero's blessing and
here's the great here we go focus
something wrong
sorry it's just your stance is your chin
up goes out to be parked back looks like
the hatched
okay how's that feel great Oh Marley
okay okay
Mack Nora get you on don't let the magic
spook you elbows elbows up
rich regard Nvidia
hey you can do this
[Music]
believe with every step you taught me
right
[Music]
[Music]
just straight ahead
yeah
[Music]
happy birthday mr. adult man
Omaha flaca gross what was dad like his
beard was Scratchy
he had a goofy laugh I wish I'd been him
I have something for you from your dad
it's a wizard staff
I wrote this spell so I can see for
myself who my boys grew up to be this
spell brings him back back way back to
life he wanted to meet you more than
anything
dad don't apart dad you are in your
house we've only got 24 hours to bring
back the rest of dad we're going on a
quest all quests starts with the
manticore the fearless adventurer you
mean Cori she's over there minutes ago
that's the man's a coil get in the
vehicle an escort yo I'm giving you to
the count of three okay wait what are
you doing I don't know I'm looking for
my son's oh they went on a quest but
don't worry
I told him about the map I told him
about the gym I told them about the
curse your boys are in great danger
[Music]
[Applause]
how your boys doing a grinder
reject not great
[Applause]
I can't do it we're not gonna see you
dad you can do this
I'm cleaning you
got knows where to go don't you boy yes
your group
on my way boys just
[Music]
I have the gift if I'm your dad
dear in and barley long ago the world
was full of magic
over time magic faded away
in Bonn word the world that gave up on
magic in favor of everyday conveniences
and in bat world needs to teenage elf
brothers have a magical opportunity it's
a wizard staff dad was a wizard to me to
their father who passed away when they
were young unfortunately it goes wrong
we only have 24 hours to bring the rest
of them backward
in Lightfoot it's kind of you know I'm
like an awkward teenager who's trying to
find himself you like parties then I'm I
was gonna do a party Tom's really great
best unit I played his big brother
barley this is bumbling well-intentioned
dingdong Oh
your chariot awaits there's something
similar about our relationship you see
it in the physicality hey Dad you look
just like I remember
Laurel adores barley and Ian so and they
go on this quest
she becomes their ears mama protect her
looking for two teenage hell's will
start at the manticores
tavern it's run by a fearless adventurer
I play Cory the man - she's not the
manticore that she once was but don't
worry I told him about the map I told
him about the gym I told him about the
curse you know this movie is going to be
a wild ride it's a really big adventure
and it's this amazing cast that Neely
brings the stories of life
[Music]